la publication australienne qui
comparait les acteurs charbon pétrole
gaz donne des notes faibles à la plupart
des producteurs d'énergie fossile et
total fait partie des moins pires je
sais pas comment on peut le dire mais la
plupart n'ont pas des stratégies
d'investissement notamment sur de
nouvelles capacités de production
cohérente avec l'accord de Paris sur le
climat c'est vraiment ça l'enjeu et ce
que vous soullignez en fait le fait de
ne pas prendre un marché ça veut dire
laisser la pas la place disponible à
d'autres en fait dans la littérature que
je lis scientifique c'est décrit comme
l'argument du dealer de drogue qui
justifie de tenir en fait un point parce
que sinon d'autres l'occupent et donc
c'est quelque chose éthiquement en fait
qui pose des questions de fond notamment
par rapport à au choix d'orientation de
financement et par rapport au choix
d'investissement qui vont ensuite amener
à chercher des débouchés et donc à
augmenter la demande par rapport aux
investissements et au retour sur
investissement moi je veux rappeler un
point c'est pas simplement l'enjeu total
énergie dont on parle
regardez COP 27 28 29 30 31 c'est une
succession de Cop dans des pays
exportateurs d'énergie fossile Égypte
émirat Arab Unis Azerbaïdjan Brésil qui
rejoint l'OPEP plus et Australie on a vu
à la COP 28 donc c'est un des S tank
extérieur qui observe ça
2456 représentation représentants du
secteur des énergies fossiles parmi les
80000 je crois participants à la COP 28
x 4 par rapport à la COP 27
donc ce qui me semble que j'observe
c'est une volonté d'être extrêmement
présent dans le cadre international des
négociation sur le climat de tous les
acteurs des énergies fossiles et ça
c'est un enjeu majeur et derrière ça
quand je regarde la stratégie total
énergie je vois qu'en Europe il s'aligne
avec les objectifs européens baisse de
la mise sur le marché de pétrole et
puis relative stagnation je crois pour
le gaz sur le marché européen par contre
recherche de nouveaux marché et
augmentation des ventes dans d'autres
régions du monde et on peut le lire de
plusieurs manières mais on peut aussi le
lire comme l'importance du cadre
réglementaire finalement qui est clair
qui est présent en Europe qui est absent
dans d'autres régions du monde euh et
aussi la faiblesse finalement des
engagements effectifs d'autres pays du
monde pour construire la décarbonation
et la maîtrise des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre on peut le lire de deux
manières en fait hein